así que aquí tenemos a nuestro vector a
que es el vector 5 - 6 y si queremos
verlo de una manera visual
bueno pues primero podemos pensar que
aquí tenemos la pola de este vector y
caminamos 5 hacia la derecha de manera
horizontal así que déjame tomar el
correspondiente color y voy a cambiar 5
en esa dirección voy a caminar cinco
unidades supongamos que llegamos hasta
acá y después hay que bajar 6 unidades
de manera vertical así que si yo me tomo
este color voy a bajar 6 unidades de
manera vertical hasta llegar a este
punto x ahora lo que quiero que te des
cuenta es que si nosotros tuviéramos
aquí 6 positivo entonces en lugar de
caminar hacia abajo caminaremos hacia
arriba pero bueno como es menos 6
entonces ya puedo decir que la distancia
es pero déjame cambiar de herramienta ya
puedo decir que la distancia que hay de
aquí hasta acá son 6 unidades
déjame ponerlo con este color son 6
unidades
que la distancia que hay de aquí acá son
5 unidades y entonces aquí tengo la cola
del vector por aquí va a estar la cabeza
del lector y este vector se va a ver de
la siguiente manera
así que si tomo este color le voy desde
este punto hasta este punto ok y déjame
dibujar la flecha de este vector a es
decir vamos en esta dirección y de lujo
aquí ya tengo mi representación de este
vector y aquí está de una manera visual
ni vector am
voy a poner que este es mi vector am y
entonces ahora que ya tengo aquí a mi
vector al que le podemos calcular a este
vector bueno lo primero que se me ocurre
es que podemos saber cuál es la magnitud
de este vector a la magnitud de este
vector a no es más que la longitud de
esta flecha que tenemos aquí y si te das
cuenta tenemos un triángulo rectángulo y
por lo tanto lo que necesitamos saber
para sacar la longitud de esta flecha
que tenemos aquí lo que tenemos que
hacer es calcular la hipotenusa de este
triángulo rectángulo que tengo aquí como
encontramos esta hipotenusa si nosotros
sabemos los otros dos lados más pequeños
bueno pues lo voy a escribir aquí la
magnitud la magnitud de este vector a
bueno esto es exactamente lo mismo que
tener la raíz cuadrada la raíz cuadrada
la suma de los cuadrados de estos dos
lados esto claro utilizando el teorema
de pitágoras y por lo tanto me va a
quedar la raíz cuadrada de 5 elevado al
cuadrado ya esto le voy a sumar a el
otro lado que es 6 elevado al cuadrado y
bueno esto es exactamente lo mismo que
cuando esto es exactamente lo mismo que
la raíz cuadrada de 25 36 25 + 36 es 61
por lo tanto la raíz cuadrada de 61 es
exactamente lo mismo que la magnitud de
este vector que es la longitud de esta
flecha que tenemos aquí y bueno si tú
quieres saber cuánto es la raíz de 61 es
un poco menos de 8 es decir que es
al lado de este triángulo rectángulo
mide 7 y cacho muy bien ahora que ya
tenemos la magnitud de este evento ahora
qué te parece si pensamos en un vector
unitario se me ocurre tomarme un vector
unitario
voy a dibujar lo más o menos aquí quiero
tomarme este vector unitario este que
tengo aquí que apunte hacia la misma
dirección que el vector a quiero un
vector que apunte hacia la misma
dirección que el vector am pero con la
diferencia de que este va a ser un
vector unitario es decir su magnitud va
a ser 1 y bueno para hacerlo más fácil
vamos a suponer que a este vector
lo llamamos 1 este va a ser mi vector
unitario 1 y como ya hemos visto en
otros vídeos ya sabemos cómo calcular a
este vector unitario para calcularlo lo
que vamos a hacer es tomarnos a este
vector am a y déjame ponerlo aquí a este
vector am ya este vector
lo voy a escalar dividiéndolo entre su
magnitud es decir voy a dividir este
vector ar
la magnitud de este mismo vector
y lo que quiero que te des cuenta es que
en este momento estoy escalando a este
vector porque lo estoy multiplicando por
un número y es más creo que para que te
quede mucho más claro esto lo podemos
representar de la siguiente manera esto
lo podemos ver como uno entre la
magnitud de este vector a la magnitud de
este vector a ok que multiplica al
vector a y creo que justo aquí ya se ve
de una manera muy clara que estamos
escalando a este vector y multiplicando
por 1 entre su magnitud y bueno esto es
lo mismo que tomarme a déjame ponerlo
así 1 entre la raíz del 61 y déjame
ponerlo por este color esta parte de
aquí es lo mismo que tomarme uno entre
la raíz de 60 y 11 entre la raíz de 61
ok que multiplica al vector a pero el
vector am es el vector
6 y déjame ponerlo aquí es el vector
déjame cerrar paréntesis de una vez ok y
le voy a tomar al 5 al 5,26 coma menos 6
ok y de esta manera encuentro a este
vector unitario hay que multiplicar cada
una de estas componentes por 1 entre la
raíz de 61 para ampliar o más bien en
este caso para disminuir este vector
y que me va a quedar pues ya puedo decir
que este vector unitario
se ve de la siguiente manera si yo
multiplico 1 entre la raíz de 61 por
estos dos componentes me va a quedar lo
siguiente me va a quedar a dgm hable y
paréntesis me va a quedar 5 entre la
raíz de 61 5 entre la raíz de 61 ok esto
si hablamos en la primera componente y
bueno ahora para obtener la segunda
componente también voy a multiplicar por
este escala que tenemos aquí y me va a
quedar menos 6
entre a la raíz de 61 ok de lujo ya
tengo aquí la expresión de este vector o
de este vector unitario y seguramente te
viene a la mente otra pregunta ya que
tengo este vector unitario porque lo
tengo que multiplicar para obtener de
nuevo el vector a porque escalar tengo
que multiplicar al vector unitario para
regresar de nuevo a mi vector a la
respuesta a esta pregunta está justo en
esta parte de aquí porque si te das
cuenta en esta parte de aquí lo que
estoy diciendo es que el vector unitario
y lo obtengo dividiendo al vector an
entre este escalar entre este escalar
que es la magnitud del vector
así que si yo quiero despejar de aquí al
vector a entonces me va a quedar lo
siguiente que la magnitud de este vector
am ok si la multiplicamos déjame ponerlo
así si a esta la multiplicamos por
el vector unitario ok y bueno date
cuenta que esto sí lo podemos hacer
porque la magnitud del vector am es
solamente un número en este caso es la
raíz de 61 es una escala que va a
multiplicar a cada una de las
componentes de este vector anterior y
con esto vamos a obtener así nuestro
vector a nuestro vector y así es la
forma de obtener de regreso este vector
arco en el que empezamos y bueno sí con
esta manera yo quisiera encontrar a este
vector am entonces puedo decir que este
vector am este vector y yo lo puedo
encontrar multiplicando déjame poner
esto es igual a la raíz de 61 a la raíz
de 61 que multiplica a este vector
unitario 1 que multiplica a este vector
unitario
y bueno esto tiene todo el sentido
lógico del mundo porque este vector
unitario tiene como longitud 1 o dicho
de otra manera este vector unitario es
es la raíz 61 décima parte de este
vector ah y bueno entonces esto me
quedaría que es exactamente lo mismo que
la raíz del 61 déjame que me dé color
que la raíz de 61 ok que va a
multiplicar a esta parte de aquí 10 más
déjame a atraparla con esto y voy a
copiar esta parte
y volver a pegar ok para ponerla justo
por aquí
es esta parte por la cam ok y bueno
justo así te vas a dar cuenta que
regresamos a este vector am si
multiplicó la raíz de 61 por cada una de
estas componentes voy a llegar al vector
5,6 y bueno realmente hice todo este
vídeo para que te sientas más cómodo con
la forma de manipular esta anotación tal
vez cuando veas este vector atrapado
entre dobles barras sea muy elegante sin
embargo solamente estamos hablando de la
magnitud de este vector y bueno el punto
de todo esto es relacionar un vector
youtube con es vector unitario que va en
la misma dirección